[Music]
you
you
uh
you
madam president the senator from utah
madam president the bill before the
senate this week
is not really about covet relief
it's about politics before this
covert relief has not been a terribly
partisan issue
in fact we've passed five relief bills
each with at least 90 votes
so these are overwhelmingly broad-based
and bipartisan
efforts so if this one
were to pass it would be the first of
those two have passed
it's been highly controversial why well
because
in the first place it borrows and spends
another 1.9
trillion dollars when there are still
hundreds of billions of dollars
of unspent relief money from past covet
19
relief packages and the new spending
authorizes money to go
to projects and states and local
governments
including many that may not even need it
the fight against the pandemic has of
course
fundamentally changed in the months
since this plan was first
devised and proposed it's already
outdated
now as as we are
here into the month of march
the circumstances have changed
and yet the plan remains largely the
same as it was and so it feels a little
bit to me
like we're fighting the last war
using the last wars battle plan leaving
us
unprepared for the battle actually in
front of us
this is a bill that will worsen our
national debt
and weaken our economy in the long run
without even doing much to help small
businesses and american families
in the short term this is not without
consequence
in fact as the the book by
dr reinhart and rogoff published nearly
10 years ago
a book known as this time it's different
notes once we get into this cycle
once we get accustomed to spending this
much
and acquiring this much of a debt to gdp
ratio
we find ourselves in dire circumstances
circumstances in which
it's even more difficult to raise the
same revenue
based on the same tax structure or even
well
uh tweaking that tax structure it can be
very difficult to pull out
of the tailspin that can be produced
when we start spending
in sums this large and perpetuating a
debt to gdp
ratio that is frankly unsustainable
this 1.9 trillion dollar package
has very very little to do with kovit
in fact only one percent of the spending
in this bill will go
toward accelerating vaccine distribution
just five percent
is focused on public health
instead according to the committee for a
responsible federal budget
three times as much money will go toward
partisan
priorities that are quote
not directly related to the current
crisis close quote
so what are some of the examples
of this type of spending well
we've got 1.5 billion dollars more
set aside for amtrak which
is itself already sitting on a billion
dollars
of unspent bailout money
and what this has to do with the virus
and why the virus somehow justifies
giving them an additional 1.5 billion
when they're already
sitting on a billion dollars of still
unspent
bailout money is beyond
my comprehension 50 million dollars in
funding for
environmental justice projects also
difficult to connect that up to covet
200 million dollars for the institute of
museum
and library services 135 million dollars
for the national endowment for the arts
135 million dollars for the national
endowment for the humanities
86 billion dollars in a pension bailout
for private sector workers
the list goes on and on but you get the
idea you get money that goes to projects
as well as a significant amount
to state and local governments we'll get
back to that in a moment
when there's as much as 63 billion
dollars left over
in unspent funds and this money will
not necessarily even help
schools to reopen
350 billion dollars in aid goes to state
and local governments
even though total losses to date have
mostly been covered by the
360 billion dollars that
congress has already provided in aid for
state and local governments over the
last year
well there's some disparity among and
between the states and how they've
responded to the covet pandemic
and how they've fared as far as their
their revenues
state and local revenue has mostly
recovered
and well 26 states saw general
revenue declines 21 states actually saw
revenue gains
in fact in my home state of utah
as well as some other states they're
running surpluses
utah's sacrifice and good governance
should not go to bail out other
profligate states to the tune of 350
billion dollars
i think about hard-working moms and dads
in utah
struggling to make ends meet well
paying their federal and state taxes
they're told over and over and over
again that they've got to be giving more
they're told that what they have spent
and the time they've allotted weeks or
months out of every year just to pay
their federal taxes alone
still somehow isn't enough isn't nearly
enough
because in addition to the money that
they've
worked so hard to earn and give to the
federal government
there's so much more that has to be
spent like 1.5 billion dollars going to
amtrak
even though it's already sitting on a
billion dollars
of unspent bailout relief
these same moms and dads throughout utah
are not pleased when they're made to
understand that
in addition to bailing out amtrak again
when amtrak's already sitting on this
billion dollars in unspent bailout
relief money that they're also going to
have to bail out
other states that they're going to have
to bail out state and local governments
that haven't been managed well
as utah's government has this isn't fair
to them this is a
matter of fundamental fairness to them
and to countless americans
not only in utah but in in every state
and some states still have unspent
funding
that they've gotten from previous covet
relief packages california alone has
8 billion dollars in unspent
funding and and new york
has up to five billion
in this bill we're acting like states
are facing a
fiscal catastrophe that is specifically
from covet
when they're not at the same time we're
acting like the
unprecedented magnitude of federal debt
is a non-issue
it is not we've got this situation
exactly backwards
now look any new
relief funding
just needs to be targeted and it needs
to be temporary
and it needs to be directly tied to
covet relief
this package is instead
about fulfilling the political wish list
of one political party over another
and has very little if anything to do
with the pandemic
it's offensive and yes it's
it's inappropriate for one political
party
the political party that clings to the
narrowest of margins
of a majority in this body
to push its own political wish list
onto an opportunity to provide covet
relief for the american people
and it would be equally inappropriate
for republicans to use it as an
opportunity to push
their own wish list
look we haven't seen this before
we haven't seen anything like this
before
we didn't in the past see any of the
previous coveted relief packages pushed
through reconciliation
there are a number of reasons for that
one of which was it's wrong
it's not an appropriate use of
reconciliation
another was it wasn't necessary because
we made it bipartisan
not just mildly bipartisan with a few
straggler votes here or there but
overwhelmingly so
this one is different i'm not opposed to
discussing what role government should
play
in providing actual relief from the
pandemic
we can and should have that debate i
welcome it i'd love to have it right now
in fact that is a question that i think
merits its own debate
this bill is not about that not anything
close to that
it's riddled with poor economic
reasoning
and rank political favoritism it'll only
worsen our debt and our economic health
in the long run it doesn't help
american small businesses and families
in the short run
it doesn't do anything to materially
advance
the cause of getting our children back
to school
at a time when they've suffered so
greatly not only academically
but socially and in so many other ways
that's where we ought to be focused this
bill
comes nowhere close to addressing that
issue
and instead it directs itself
in other directions that are not only
not helpful but in many cases they're
the opposite of that
it's sad it's disappointing
and on that basis i can't support this
bill but would urge my colleagues
and figure out ways to make it better we
don't have to do it this way
it doesn't have to be a deeply partisan
vote
we can still choose a different path i
for one hope we will
thank you madam prison
adam president the senator from
pennsylvania
thank you madam president um the
circumstances that we face
today on in the senate are
so disturbing uh this is really really
unbelievable
i mean there's so much good news out
there on the health care front on the on
on
the pandemic front on the economic front
but what we're
going to do in this chamber is
absolutely
absolutely appalling the members of this
chamber
came together five times last year
and passed overwhelmingly bipartisan
bills to deal with this pandemic to deal
with the economic crisis that came from
the lockdown
that we experienced five times
about four trillion dollars completely
unprecedented in scope and scale the
nature of it and
never imagined before but we did it we
did it because
we needed to and we came together
i think the biggest of the bills passed
the biggest by far
without a single no vote in this whole
chamber
completely bipartisan so president biden
gets
elected gives a great speech great
inaugural speech about uniting the
country coming together we don't have to
be
divided the way we have been we can we
can work together and find common ground
so 10 republican senators go down to the
white house and say well mr president i
know you you've got
you'd like to do 1.9 trillion whatever
it is
but we'll we'll we we think there's a
good case for 600 billion dollars
now i don't have to agree with those 10
republican centers as it happens
i don't think that even that is
appropriate but they did
and the reason that's significant is
because there were 10 of them
which just so happens to be exactly the
minimum number needed of republican
senators to join with the democrats to
pass anything they want
on a bipartisan basis so
there handed to him on a silver platter
to the president
was the opportunity to do a bipartisan
bill
to figure out where that common ground
was the republicans were offering to
negotiate from there
this probably could have easily ended at
a trillion dollars or so
after just weeks before passing a
trillion dollar bill
the president could have gotten so much
of what he wanted but president biden
didn't want any part of that
and you've got to ask yourself why is
that
when he campaigned as the guy who's
going to
unify america and he had every
republican vote he needed
sitting in his office asking him to work
this out
and he said no not interested
effectively that's what he said
well when you look at the bill it's
clear why
president biden chose this path
because there's no justification for
this bill
there's no medical justification there's
no pandemic justification there's no
economic justification
this isn't about coming together and
doing something about a crisis
this is about a partisan left-wing wish
list
and of course republicans aren't
interested in that kind of
political gesturing that's going to do
economic damage
i'm reminded of the words of
rahm emanuel who famously said you never
want a serious crisis to go to waste
rahm emanuel must be very proud of
our democratic colleagues and president
biden
because what they've done is they've
taken a crisis that's rapidly receding
let's be honest
and they've decided this is their chance
to make one last mad dash for the door
with a staggering amount of money
and presumably claim credit for the
recovery that's already well underway
the good news is there's a lot of good
news
right um we we went through one of the
most trying times we've been through in
a very long time in this country this
pandemic
was devastating it was deadly it was
scary
and the economic crisis was very very
real but now
we've got a hundred and over a hundred
million
doses of vaccines have gone into
people's arms
when you figure that we've might very
well have a hundred million
americans who've had the disease and
recovered we've got
got to have well over half of the
american population
has either recovered or been vaccinated
is therefore no longer
at risk to this disease not in a
significant risk
and that's fantastic news and by the way
the the vaccine
administration is accelerating and so
following that we are unsurprisingly
seeing this terrific collapse in the
number of
new cases the daily count of new cases
of the coronavirus of covet 19
peaked at around 250 000 new cases in a
single day
we were we were running at that pace by
the time we got to the inauguration of
president biden we were down to 185 000
and yesterday it was about 60 000 so
less than a quarter
of the number of new cases on a daily
basis
that we were experiencing at the peak
and it continues to drop it's going to
continue to decline probably very
rapidly
as we continue to roll out these
vaccines that's terrific
and there is a sort of parallel recovery
of the economy underway
if you go back to april of 2020 when it
was at its worst
the unemployment rate was almost 15 14.8
that's a terrible terrible unemployment
rate
as of january of this year just a few
months ago
the unemployment rate was 6.3 less than
half
where we were now we're not back to the
fantastic economy we had
a year ago just before this pandemic
broke
but we're getting there and 18 states
across the country have unemployment
rates below five percent
to the tremendous ingenuity of the
private sector to come
up with vaccines that are incredibly
effective
several of them and do it in a record
time i mean a fraction
of what was the previous record time
it's amazing
and yeah you know what we played a role
in this too i think we did
the bipartisan cooperation in congress
to pass one bill after another on a huge
scale like i said five bills
the biggest without a single dissent
actually i'm not sure any of them had a
dissenting vote
in the senate and almost a trillion
in december leaving tens of billions of
dollars that we've approved that hasn't
even been spent yet
no the the intended beneficiaries have
not gotten the money yet
it takes a little while to get the money
out the door so given this context given
this history this is why it's so
dispiriting
to see our democratic colleagues
insisting on a bill
that has almost nothing to do with covet
that's the truth it is not about
reopening the economy
it's a partisan left-wing spending
binge that's what it is let's take a
look at some of the individual items
we've got these so-called stimulus
checks i never heard anything more
inaptly named 414 billion dollars
the fact is real personal income in the
country
is today higher than it was just before
the pandemic
disposable reel per capita income rose
at its highest rate since 1984.
personal savings rate hit an all-time
record high in 2020.
why because we more than replaced lost
income
through all of the bills that we passed
so what about that data suggests we need
another round of universal payments to
people
it's not going to stimulate the economy
the last
even the last check 60 of that money
went to
savings accounts or paying down debt
according to a penn warden study
about 75 of these checks are going to go
into savings and why in the world are we
sending
so many checks to tens of millions of
people
who've never had any lost income so
under this bill the federal government's
going to send out
5 600 to a family of four 5
600 to a family of four that makes 150
000 a year and never had a dime of
income lost
no interruption of income no loss of
income
they're going to get 5 600 and that by
the way that's on top of the 5800
they already got last year
with no need no demonstrated problem
here
11 thousand four hundred dollars of
money that we don't have that we're
gonna send to people who've never had a
dime of lost income
that's a big chunk of this bill but it
it may not be the worst it may be that
the worst
is the 350 billion dollars we're going
to send
to state and local governments to bail
out the mismanaged blue states
and cities and the amazing thing is
you can't possibly make the case that
they need the bailout
they don't even need it why do i say
that well if you look in
2020 the books are closed now we know
what we didn't know early in the year of
2020 we're in 2021 now we know what
happened in 2020
and what happened was states and
municipalities in the aggregate
brought in more revenue in 2020 than
they did in 2019
which was a record year so they've set
an all-time new record
for tax revenue collected
all-time new record and that does not
include
the 500 billion dollars we sent them
anyway
i think these states are loaded with
cash
i don't know what they're going to do
with it there's 60 billion dollars
in rainy day funds we heard oh my
goodness these states are going to have
to cut essential services all the
teachers are going to be laid off
the firemen and the police officers it's
all done
how is that when they've taken in more
revenue than they ever have before
in their history and then we sent them
another 500 billion dollars
so now we're going to send them yet
another 350 on top of this
how does this make any sense at all
we're going to go and borrow or print
this money
so that we can send it to a bunch of
states many of whom are
should be sitting on so much cash
they're going to i don't know probably
cut taxes
it's just unbelievable then there's the
obamacare
expansion what does that have to do with
covet
this is just a decade-long goal of our
democratic colleagues to continue
the endless expansion of obamacare so 45
billion dollars in this bill
to pay insurance companies more money to
cover people who already have health
insurance
that's what they're doing 63
of these new subsidies will go to people
who already have health insurance
through obamacare and by the way it
includes
it includes huge numbers of people that
make over a hundred thousand dollars a
year
never miss a chance to make more people
dependent on government
it's got policies big policies that will
absolutely slow the economic recovery so
let me be clear
these this bill will slow down
the economic recovery underway why do i
say that well
the bill insists on adding 400 a week
on top of whatever states are paying in
unemployment benefits
well what does that mean it means that
more than half
of everyone who's unemployed is going to
get paid
more not to work than they get paid
working what
who could even think this up we've had
unemployment insurance for decades in
this country
we have never said let us systematically
make sure that people can make more
money not working
than they can make if they go to work i
hear some of my colleagues talk a lot
about the dignity of work
i think there's a lot of dignity in work
what is our message to people about the
dignity of work when we say
you know you're more worth more to us
sitting on the couch than you are at
your job
that's what this is it's terrible idea
and and how do you know for sure that
nobody on the other side is even
pretending that this is really about the
economic recovery
well you know for sure because the
congressional budget office has told
us that only a fraction a small fraction
of this money
is even going to be spent this year how
long do we think the pandemic is going
to
be with us as a pandemic how long do we
think we're going to have these
lockdowns
we're going to be out of the woods
pretty soon here
well as i said we've got half of all
americans are already have been either
vaccinated or recovered
from this but the the school number is a
good illustration the elementary and
secondary education
this bill has a 128 billion dollars
128 billion dollars
six and a half billion is going to be
spent in 2021
the rest gets dribbled out for years and
years and years how long do they think
before schools can reopen oh and by the
way
this bill doesn't require the schools to
reopen you don't even have to reopen
just throw billions and billions and
billions of dollars at schools whether
or not
they're actually having kids in the
school
and some of these provisions are so
blatantly
unrelated to covet or the economy it's
really just hard to even
read them with a straight face 86
billion dollars to bail out multiplayer
pension
plans without any reform whatsoever
now look we all know we have a
multi-employer pension
problem in this country and there's been
a lot of discussion about
what do you do about these grossly
underfunded pension plans
and how do you fix this and the
conversation has always been
what kind of reforms come with what kind
of cash
so that these th these errors of the
past
are corrected there's no there's no
reforms here none nothing
just a big pile of cash it's a clear
message that you don't have to fix
anything
you don't have to reform the flaws of
these programs that got us here
and by the way it's the same message to
the insolvent public pension plans
of most of the major cities in many
states
don't worry look what congress will do
and if if the democrats have their way
they'll just send you so much cash you
don't have to worry about the insolvency
you're dealing with
what a terrible message
270 million dollars for the national
endowment for the arts and humanities oh
that's coped related
thank goodness that's there 91 million
dollars for
outreach to student loan borrowers i
don't even know what that means
50 million dollars for environmental
justice grants i have no idea what that
means
but this one is really rich there's
about four billion dollars for
socially disadvantaged farmers and
ranchers i say about 4 billion
because it says such sums as may be
necessary
and here's what the money is for
it's going to pay off 120 percent
of the debt of these farmers and
ranchers 120 percent
of the borrowings so what in the world
are the requirements
to have 120 percent of your debt
paid off well
you actually have to have debt okay so
you have to have borrowed money
from the usda farm loan tens of billions
of dollars out there
they lend a lot of money and you have to
be a member of one of the following
groups
african-american american indian alaskan
native
asian hispanic pacific islanders
refugees or immigrants
as long as you're in one of those
categories of racial ethnic
mostly racial and ethnic groups
then the taxpayer is going to pay off
120 not not the whole loan
more than the whole loan 120
and the thing that's so disturbing about
this
is that the essential criteria is your
skin color
the essential criteria is your race
i this is unbelievable to me there by
the way there's no income test
there's no asset test for the underlying
loans
there's no requirement whatsoever that
kovid
caused any problem caused any lost
income or any other
problem it's not it's not mentioned
so what's the effect of this this means
that if you have a wealthy
hispanic rancher who's got a million
dollar loan from the usda
he's going to get 1.2 million dollars
and pay off the loan
200 000 bucks to do with whatever he
likes
and meanwhile if you're a poor white
farmer in rural pennsylvania and you
have a hundred thousand dollar loan
you get nothing exactly enough how is
that even remotely fair
i don't know how that could even be
constitutional
but certainly not in any way covalented
there was a an amendment in the house
that would have limited the payment it
would allow the program which i object
to but it would allow this
repayment of debt but only for debt
incurred during the
coveted crisis democrats all voted that
down
that failed this is unbelievable stuff
you know even the provisions that
purport to be about
public health are completely divorced
from any reality
you know as i think i mentioned earlier
we're administering
almost 2 million doses of vaccines every
day now
it's terrific it's actually the highest
daily rate of doses administered
anywhere in the world
the government has already purchased 700
million doses
now we've got less than 350 million
americans and not all americans are
going to need two doses so
you can do the math we have bought more
vaccine doses
than we need to administer that's fine
but how many more do you need to buy
when you've already bought more than
enough for every single american
and that's not all we paid for through
the previous bills that we passed
we paid for the research and development
we paid for the production
we paid for the transportation we paid
for all the accompanying supplies like
syringes and the vials and the dry ice
we paid for all that
and we should have that was the right
thing to do
insurance covers the cost of the
administering of
the vaccines between medicare and
medicaid and private insurance
it's free what is left to spend money on
i'm all ears but i haven't heard
what we need to spend money on
so so what do we have in this bill we
have no justification for it in terms of
public health
we certainly have no justification for
it in terms of
the economy we certainly have no
justification in terms of basic fairness
and frankly it's going to do more harm
than good but you don't have to take my
word for it
we could take the word of prominent
liberal
democrat economists larry summers
he was a treasury secretary under
president clinton
he was the director of the national
economic council under president obama
and he said and i quote about this bill
macroeconomic stimulus on a scale closer
to world war
ii levels than normal recession levels
will set off inflationary pressures of a
kind that we have not
seen in a generation end quote
or consider the words of steve ratner
who's a liberal
economist uh president obama named him
the karzar
you may recall him administering that
program he said and i quote
the american rescue plan that's
apparently what they call this he said
the american rescue plan
is also partly a legislative trojan
horse
an enormous aid package aimed at
addressing needs that in some cases
go well beyond the immediate challenges
of covid
some of the most expensive provisions
are the least well
targeted to help the neediest end quote
and that's from a liberal democrat who i
think supports the bill
but at least he's being honest in his
description of it so madam president
my suggestion my plea to my democratic
colleagues to the new president
listen to some of the things you've said
try an approach that's actually informed
by
the facts on the ground the the health
facts the economic facts the reality
look at what the science is currently
telling us about the course that this
virus
has been taking and what about actually
attempting
to bring people together the path of
unity after we demonstrated five times
last year that we can work together and
do something on a bipartisan basis
i urge my colleagues don't push through
this radically partisan bill
that will probably in the end do more
harm than good and i yield the floor
madam president the senator from
wisconsin
madam president let me first say i wish
that this chamber was full
of our colleagues to listen to my
republican
colleague the senator from
pennsylvania's uh description of of what
this bill
is and what this bill isn't and it's not
a covert relief bill
and senator tommy did an excellent job
i'm hoping people are watching it
on their tv screens because they really
can't be reading the bill yet because
it's not constructed i don't want to
repeat with the senator from
pennsylvania
all the excellent points he made but i
want to come down
because i think we've grown immune to
these vast
amounts of money i always knew we were
going to be in big trouble
when we stopped talking about hundreds
of billions of dollars and switched to
talking about trillions of dollars and
so we talk about 1 trillion or 2
trillion it
just doesn't sound as much as a couple
hundred billion or 800 billion dollars
which was
the stimulus package under the obama
administration
uh the fact of the matter is we have
already authorized
four trillion dollars in covert relief
that's 18
of last year's gdp and roughly a
trillion dollars is yet to be spent
some of that isn't even obligated and
here we are we're going to be debating
over the next couple days
1.9 trillion dollars so i just wanted to
come down
here to the floor and try and
illustrate what a massive amount of
money
1.5 trillion dollars is or 1.9
trillion dollars you have to use
analogies
again the human mind really can't
contemplate
what a trillion is i found this first
analogy my wife talked to me about it
in terms of time so
this one is simply talking about it if
if i would give you madam president a
dollar per second
a dollar per second how much how long
would it take me to give you a million
dollars
let me see the chart here it would take
11.6 days
again a dollar per second how much for a
million dollars 11.6 days
next question how long would it take you
to accumulate
a billion dollars going to do the math
you find out would take
31.7 years
that's back when the chinese had their
protests in tiananmen square
so the next the next question is what
about a trillion dollars and this is
what becomes
mind-boggling if i gave you a dollar
every second
and i wanted to give you a trillion
dollars it would take
31 688 years
to give you a trillion dollars that that
that takes us back to the
beyond the last glaciation period
a period in time when wisconsin was
under a
a mild fit glacier by the way a quick
little side for
my colleague from center from rhode
island
since that point in time about 20 000
years ago the the i
the water level in the bay of san
francisco has increased 390 feet
now that's global warming that's a rise
in the sea level but that's what
happened through natural causes but that
was an aside
so how long would it take to accumulate
1.9 trillion dollars
60 000 years over 60
000 years again put that in context the
human race
began to develop language about 50 000
years ago
so that's the time analogy another way
of looking at this is
is through distance and volume
so so here's the calculation i should
have brought a dollar bill to just
demonstrate
its thickness but the thickness of a
dollar bill is
4.3 thousandths of an inch thick
so to illustrate how much a trillion
dollars is let's start with a million
if you stack the million dollar bills on
top of each other
they would be they would stack up to be
358 feet high
you can see the calculation here
that's about a 30 to 35 foot story
building
so how big would a stack of a billion
dollar bills be it'd be 67.86
miles now there's something called the
the carmen line i think i'm pronouncing
that right that's that's this
the point where the atmosphere ends and
outer space begins
that's the 62 miles so a stack of a
billion dollars would actually exceed
the atmosphere and extend into outer
space
67 miles so again the next question is
well how big is would a stack be of a
trillion dollar bills
well it's a thousand times that so it'd
be 67
866 miles high
that's an astonishingly large stack of
dollar bills
that equals a trillion dollars but again
we're not talking just a trillion
dollars we're not talking about just 67
miles worth we're talking about 1.9
trillion dollars
which would stack up to 135
732 miles high
madam president the distance to the moon
is 238
900 miles so that stack
of 1.9 trillion dollars worth of one
dollar bills
would be more than halfway to the moon
that is what we are debating spending
a stack of dollar bills that extends
more than halfway
the distance to the moon and this is at
a point in time when we're about 28
trillion dollars in debt
that single stack would be over 1.9
million miles
or if you put it relative to the moon
that would be eight stacks
seven stacks to go directly to the moon
and one further stack that's 95
of the way there
these are astonishing sums that we're
talking about and
the majority party here wants to jam
this through through a reconciliation
process
no consultation with with our side
just blow it through here 20 hours of
debate a vote-a-rama pass
1.9 trillion dollars in spending
and go home having no consideration
whatsoever the fact that we are
mortgaging our children's future at some
point time there will be a day of
reckoning a debt crisis
and it won't be pretty my suggestion
at least as we consider this
is let's actually have a debate let's
have a discussion
let's consider the amendments let's not
do this in
in 20 24 or 30 hours let's take the time
to seriously consider what we are doing
to our children
in contemplating spending a stack of
dollar bills
over 135 miles high
extending more than halfway to the moon
with that madam president i yield the
floor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
uh
foreign
ms baldwin
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
hmm
so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
foreign
uh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
foreign
okay
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
madam president the senator from ohio
thank you madam president i ask the
spencer quora
without objection thank you madam
president this week
we have an opportunity to finally
deliver for millions of retirees and
workers and small businesses
by saving america's pensions the
multi-employer pension systems on the
verge of collapse
threatening the livelihoods of more than
a million
more than a million americans and
thousands of small businesses from new
hampshire
to ohio across the country this affects
more than a hundred thousand workers and
retirees in my state alone
and millions more around the country
these pension plans
were in danger before now the economic
emergency we're in has accelerated the
crisis
even further multi-employer pension
plans receive
contributions based on the hours worked
as workers have been laid off during the
pandemic their employers no longer
contribute to the pension plans
while current retirees continue
receiving their earned benefits making
the plan
even more likely to fail and if that
happens madam president
it won't just be retirees feeling the
pain
current workers will be stuck paying
into pension funds
for benefits they'll never receive small
businesses will be left drowning in
pension liability
they can't afford to pay small
businesses that have been in the family
for generations
could face bankruptcy and workers will
lose jobs at businesses
which have been forced to close up shop
the effect will ripple across the entire
economy
in a time when we can least afford it
the chamber of commerce has said the
multi-employer pension system
is an integral part of our economy it's
not only union businesses that
participate in these plans that will
close their doors
this will devastate small communities
across the industrial heartland
small businesses in these communities
are already hurting
because of the virus that's why we have
to get this done
after a lifetime of hard work in service
to our country
these workers and retirees have already
waited far too long for congress to do
the job we should have done
we've been trying to solve this for
years unions the chamber of commerce
small businesses pretty much
agree we need to get this done the house
has done its part
they passed a solution multiple times
every time it stopped because of mitch
mcconnell
in the united states senate he has
deliberately blocked it
we have continued to try the house does
it year after year
people like the presiding officer and
others have fought for this and the
finance committee have fought for this
on the senate floor and we simply
haven't been able to move it
now senator mcconnell's out of the way
and we can finally keep the promise to
these workers and their families
they spent years working on assembly
lines bagging groceries driving trucks
working to keep our economy going and
the money and money came out of every
single one of their paychecks
to earn these pensions people in this
town don't always understand the
collective bargaining process
people give up dollars at the bargaining
table today
for the promise of a secure retirement
with health care and a pension that's
what collective bargaining is
union workers sit down with each other
and their employer
to talk about giving up wage and are
willing to give up wages today
to have a more secure future what's
what's more american than that
and for years now they've lived in fear
of drastic cuts
one retiree from michigan told us he'd
lose two-thirds of
his income and that it's 71 years old
there's no jobs out there
that he could recover what we'd love
that we could get to recover what we'd
lose
he said pass the butch lewis act so we
can take this weight off of us and
retire with the dignity
that we earn for 30 40 50 years of
hard-working labor
it's always the same story when wall
street's in trouble there's a bailout
when corporation needs something the
stock market's in trouble the washington
elite drop
everything to help but these workers
they're not asking for a bailout
they're not asking for a handout they're
just asking for what
they earn these workers have been in the
fight for years
their activism has gotten us this far
they've traveled all day and all night
on buses they've rallied outside in the
bitter cold
in the hot dc summer all trying to get
people in this town to listen
let's finally deliver for them let's
give them peace of mind let's keep this
promise
it comes back to the dignity of work
when work has dignity
we honor the retirement security people
earn when work has dignity we honor
their retirement security that they gave
up at the bargaining table
in collective bargaining i urge my
republican colleagues in this body
colleagues
with health care and retirement plans
paid for by taxpayers including these
taxpayers
that have been paying into their own
pension fund for years
i urge my republican colleagues to think
about these retired workers and think
about the small business owners
companies like smuckers company there's
a baker in in navarre
ohio think of the candy company spangler
and bryan ohio
companies like that think about these
retired workers think about these small
business owners
think about the stress they're facing
i've listened to my colleague speeches
for years
extolling the values of hard work in the
virtue of small businesses
this is your chance to live up to your
own words
to show americans if you work hard all
your life your government will in fact
be there for you
join us let's pass a solution that
really indeed does
honor the dignity of work
madam president i note the absence of
core
the clerk will call the role ms baldwin
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
breaking
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
so
do
[Music]
uh
wow
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
ah
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
madam president the senator from alaska
madam president asked that the quorum
call be initiated
without objection madam president it's
that time of the week
that uh you know our pages when we had
them
used to always look forward to it's the
time of week that i come
come down on the floor and talk about
someone in alaska who's
making a huge impact on my state a lot
of times
for the country these two alaskans i'm
gonna talk about actually have gotten
national news for the great work that
they're doing
somebody we call our alaskans of the
week and it's
usually about a group of individuals one
two maybe a group of people who are
helping make
alaska what in my view is the greatest
state in the country
resilient tough generous kind unique
and uh madam president like so many
states this pandemic has really hit
alaska hard tourism for sure the oil and
gas
sector last year really hit hard with
low prices
unfortunately this year with the biden
administration's attacks
on this sector the u.s and alaska
economy
it's tough commercial fishing tough
it's been a tough year economically but
in an area good news during the pandemic
one that i'm very proud of
for all my constituents involving how
we in alaska have responded on the
health side
vaccines testing
death rates we have consistently been
the top state rated in all of these
categories
throughout the pandemic which is kind of
amazing
given that we are a very very big state
with a very
small population i know that so many
americans watching right now they want
to get back out
visit alaska our governor mike dunleavy
recently tweeted
with the best vaccination efforts
in the country and some of the lowest
covered numbers
in the country alaska is open for
business
safe for travelers so come on america
get back up to alaska love to have you
so this is all very true our vaccination
efforts
are viewed as the best in the united
states of america and the great lengths
that so many in alaska have gone
through to make it so
have captured the country's imagination
these efforts just in the last couple
weeks have been featured
all across the country usa today good
morning america the washington post the
new york times
a great piece by bloomberg news and so
many others so big thanks
to the press corps national press corps
for featuring my state's efforts and
importantly the heroic work
being done to distribute life-saving
vaccines
to a state that is more than
two and a half times the size of texas
sorry there senator cornyn senator cruz
it's true
and most of the geography of alaska is
dotted with small villages without roads
in freezing cold temperatures
i was in fairbanks last weekend just a
couple weeks ago in fairbanks almost hit
40 below
that is cold all across alaska our
healthcare workers are jumping on boats
single prop airplanes snow machines and
yes
in a couple cases dog sleds
to bring the vaccine and hope
to their fellow alaskans and it shows
as of a few days ago
close to a hundred and sixty thousand
alaskans received at least their first
vaccine dose that is
about 21 percent of our state's
population
now madam president in southwest alaska
what we call the yukon kuskokwim delta
or the yk
delta those are two giant rivers that
come together
these efforts have been particularly
impressive
that's largely thanks to the amazing
people at the yk
health corporation or ykhc
which is the yk delta's
tribal health provider the whole
organization
consisting just about 90 health care
professionals serves around 28
000 peoples in the yk region which is
about the size of oregon
so huge area not a lot of people
and prior to the vaccine
the yk delta had been stricken by coven
19
with one of the highest infection rates
in the country
in a very far-flung place in terms of
the disbursement of the population but
it's the efforts of two women there
in the yk delta doctors ellen hodges
and elizabeth bates who are our alaskans
of the week
who have been in charge getting the
vaccine
to roughly 50 remote villages in
southwestern alaska
spread out over a territory as i said
about the size of oregon
the village populations in the yk delta
range
from about 1200 people to as small as 10
in terms of population
so let's start with dr hodges she is the
chief of staff at ykhc she grew up in
rural
minnesota after graduating from the
university of minnesota medical school
dr hodges came to anchorage as a
resident in 2002
eventually making her way to bethel
which is the hub
village it's a big community the biggest
in the yk delta
she absolutely fell in love with the
area
she said it has everything very friendly
people
authentic it's beautiful soon enough
her patience turned into her family
also soon enough she was according to
trisha franklin alaska's director of the
state
office of rural health division she was
dr hodges the go-to person
for how things are working in rural
communities and how to get things done
she worked in the emergency room tending
cuts bruises broken bones she delivered
babies
she worked tirelessly to contain
a number of serious tuberculosis
outbreaks in the region
and then madam president the virus hit
and as i mentioned
it hit the yk delta region very hard
with some of the highest
covert rates in america and there are
reasons for that
the multi-generational housing very
crowded housing
in this region communal lifestyle
and also here's a big one madam
president
and it should be a shock for every
american listening
about 50 percent of the households in
this region of america
lack running water
let me say that again some of the most
patriotic
communities in the country because
alaska natives serve at higher rates in
the military than any other ethnic group
in the country live in communities that
don't have
running water or flush toilets american
citizens
it's wrong that's wrong and we need we
the u.s senate
congress need to continue to work on
this issue how do you wash your hands
five
times a day but as the cdc wants you to
do during the pandemic when you don't
have
running water or flush toilets
we need to keep working on this it's a
disgrace to be honest
so what happened when covent hid in this
region
because of a lack of sanitation and many
other problems
precious lives were being lost elders
who are vital to pass on the traditional
wisdom
of the native alaskan culture and
heritage were being lost
and because of a lack of functioning
sanitation even young people
which this virus doesn't really impact
we're starting to have respiratory
illnesses and getting sick and some are
even dying
that's horrible it was terrifying
particularly for an area that is still
dealing with the multi-generational
trauma
of previous pandemics particularly
the spanish flu of 1918 which in several
alaska native communities
wiped out entire communities 60
70 percent mortality rates from that flu
so we needed to get to work fast
particularly in this region
enter another intrepid doctor and our
other alaskan of the week dr elizabeth
bates dr bates arrived in bethel in
december
2018 just a little over two years ago
and she found a community that she loved
she had experience working in women's
health in infection control
in emergency care and disaster relief
she had great experience across the
country really across the world
as a doctor she worked with patients
during 9 11
hurricane katrina and had spent time
even in refugee camps in rwanda
in bethel she was in charge of setting
up testing centers for the region
working hand in glove with dr hodges
she started one of the first drive-thru
in airport testing sites in rural alaska
much of it outside in the cold weather
under tarps
but we all know madam president that
testing alone
particularly as i said when people are
living so close together
and don't live in places where you can
wash your hands
frequently testing alone wasn't nearly
enough
they tried everything public service
announcements
reaching out to villagers helping them
use bleach to sanitize it was a
24 7 effort but as i said it wasn't
enough
the virus was spreading rapidly
they were losing people were dying
and then on december 18th
a few days before winter solstice the
darkest day of the year
hope came to bethel alaska
because the first vaccines arrived
thanks to the great work of so many
scientists
government workers private sector
workers operation warp speed
the vaccine arrived december 18th
the yk delta these two intrepid doctors
i've been talking about
cried they had seen a lot
of death and struggles in the region
and like a christmas miracle this
vaccine
arrived they hugged each other and then
they got to work
as i said there are roughly 50 remote
villages in the yk delta spread out
over a territory about the size
of many states and our countries maybe
bigger than most states
in our country so they traveled on small
planes
trucks on ice roads snow machines dog
sleds
their operation project togo
named in reference to one of the famous
sled dogs
that helped carry the diphtheria serum
to gnome which of course is the
original inspiration for the iditarod
sled dog race
sometimes it was so cold that they had
to keep the fringes filled with coveted
serum under their clothes
lest the serum froze the operation
that they initiated and organized has
hit
every single village all 50 in the yk
delta
bringing the vaccine to pretty much
anyone who wants it
in some villages they've been able to
vaccinate as much as half the population
as a result the numbers of coveted
infections and deaths are plummeting
in this region and hope is spreading
this great team dr hodges and bates as
well as
all in the community
and all working at ykhc
have made a huge difference and this
team
has created a special bond
that nobody will forget dr bates a
relative newcomer in alaska says that
the experience has made her fall in love
with the yk delta region even more
she bought a home she intends on staying
she describes the beauty of the region
something that she appreciates even more
now is quote
our sky is huge we have a front
row seat for the entire
universe these two doctors also
have a front row seat and providing a
front row seat
to hope during this pandemic
so i want to thank both of them again dr
hodges and dr bates
and to all those across alaska
who are helping distribute the vaccine
as i mentioned right now alaska is the
number one state in the country per
capita
in terms of vaccine distribution in the
number one state
per capita in terms of testing
in one of the lowest death rates
this is really amazing really when you
see how big
and widespread and harsh the weather
conditions can be in the great state of
alaska
our fellow alaskans are tough resilient
innovative and dr hodges and dr bates
are a huge and essential part of this
effort
and that's why i want to congratulate
them and thank them
again for being our alaskans
of the week i yield the floor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
uh
uh
[Music]
madam president
the assistant majority leader as consent
the quorum call be suspended
we are not in the quorum call thank you
very much i ask unanimous consent the
committee on
health education labor and pensions be
discharged from further consideration of
s 164 and the senate proceed to its
immediate consideration
the clerk will report
s-164 a bill to educate health care
providers and the public
on biosimilar biological products
and for other purposes
without objection the committee is
discharged and the senate will proceed
to the measure
i ask unanimous consent the bill be
considered red a third time in past the
motions to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table
without objection madam president i ask
unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to the immediate consideration
of s-578 which was introduced earlier
today
the clerk will report s-578
a bill to improve the health and safety
of americans
living with food allergies and so forth
and for other purposes
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure i further asked
the bill we read a third time and passed
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
without objection and a president i
asked unanimous consent the senate
proceeded immediate consideration of
s-579 which was introduced earlier today
the clerk will report s-579
a bill to make a technical correction to
the als
disability insurance access act of 2019.
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure i further asked
the bill we read a third time in past
the motion to reconsider be considered
made laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
without objection
and president i ask unanimous consent
the senate now proceed to the on-block
consideration
of the following senate resolutions
which were submitted earlier today
sres 90 school counseling week s res 91
cte month s res 92 speech and debate
education day
estress 93 university of alabama crimson
tide
without objection the senate will
proceed to the resolutions on block
i ask unanimous consent that the
resolutions be agreed to the preambles
be agreed to
the motions to reconsider be considered
made laid upon the table
all on block without objection at a
president i ask unanimous consent the
senate proceed to the consideration of
sres94
submitted earlier today the clerk will
report
senate resolution 94 designating the
week beginning february 28
2021 as national tribal
colleges and universities week
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure i know of no
further debate on the resolution
if there's no further debate the
question is on the resolution
all in favor say aye aye all opposed no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the resolution is agreed to i ask
unanimous consent that the preamble be
agreed to that the motions to reconsider
be considered made and laid upon the
table with no intervening action or
debate
without objection madam president i ask
unanimous consent that when the senate
completes its business today it adjourn
until 12
noon thursday march the 4th that
following the prayer and pledge the
morning hour be deemed expired the
journal proceedings be approved to date
and the time for the two leaders be
reserved for their use later in the day
the morning business be closed
without objection if there's no further
business to come for the senate i ask
that it stand adjourned under the
previous order
the senate stands adjourned till 12 noon
tomorrow
you